[Music]
hi my name is Callum Barnes I'm the head
of product for speech in Google Cloud
today I'm going to be talking about
Google Cloud speech to text
text-to-speech and how you can use them
to power new voice interfaces later in
the session we'll hear from Ryan wheeler
from Toyota connected about how Toyota
is using speech in their vehicles
I'm going to start off by talking a
little bit about the history and Legacy
of speech here at Google then tell you
all about our offerings in Cloud
and what I'm most excited about is today
we're going to be introducing two new
speech and voice Technologies one is
speech on device the ability to run
speech and text-to-speech models locally
on devices as well as feature text API
V2 our latest and greatest on the cloud
side
let's get started by telling you a
little bit about the last 20 years of
speech at Google though
Google really started working on speech
in 2001 and the very first speech
product we introduced was actually
called 1-800 goog 411
this gave you the ability to call up
Google and speak your search query
before everybody had access to the
internet this was mostly like white
pages queries for businesses and other
types of information that you might be
able to get from the search engine even
if you didn't have access to the
internet
as you can imagine this wasn't around
for very long before most people were
online and the ability to call Google
wasn't needed
however Google continued to leverage
this Research into the speech space
to launch Google Voice search in 2010
most of you have probably experienced
this at one time or another whether it's
pressing the microphone button to search
on your mobile phone uh or on the
desktop so that you don't need to type
your query
this Legacy and these languages that
they started on in speech gave way to
years and years of research at Google
into speech technology
in 2010 Google was one of the first to
apply what were at the time modern
machine learning techniques to speech
recognition so that they could more
robust and more accurately transcribe
short utterances This research
ultimately gave way to the availability
of Google assistant and other voice
agent and virtual assistant Technologies
on the Google Cloud side in 2017 we
first announced the availability of
Google Cloud speech to text which gave
Enterprises their first ability to take
advantage of what at the time was 15
years of speech work and research from
Google
fast forward to today we have even more
research coming out and we continue to
make the latest and greatest speech
research including things like
end-to-end conformer speech models
talkatron text-to-speech models
available to all Google Cloud customers
as you can see from all these products
it's not just Cloud speeches everywhere
at Google whether that's interacting
with the Google Assistant seeing
captions in YouTube interacting with
Android apps that have speech features
or seeing live captions in Google meet
our goal in Google cloud is to take all
of this technology and all the expertise
around speech and voice that have been
built up at Google over the years and
make them available to Enterprises to
use in their own applications and power
their own voice experiences
so let's talk about what tools we have
today in Google Cloud for developers and
companies to build and leverage these
Technologies
with our first offering we have the
speech to text API this is an automatic
speech recognition system that allows
developers to send audio to the cloud
and get the transcription text directly
back
what's great about this API is that you
can get high quality results right out
of the box without ever having to do any
training customization or tune in on the
model you can really get started on day
one
it's easy to get started in any language
because we have support for over 75
languages in 120 different locales
this means that no matter what language
your audio is in you can get started
with just the API without needing to do
anything else
now our goal is to give high quality
results in as many cases as possible but
we understand that for some use cases
customization is going to be necessary
and that's why the speech text API is
extremely flexible you can use it with
multiple channels of audio multiple
speakers in the same channel to separate
them you can have
unspoken punctuation to automatically
insert marks into text or spoken
punctuation if you want users to be able
to dictate the punctuation that they're
looking for
of course we also know that some use
cases require modifications and tuning
of the speech-to-text models in order to
get the best results usually that could
be for specific industry terms specific
company names
Etc and you can use the speech
adaptation API to tune the speech model
to get the best results every time this
is true whether you're trying to
understand a specific brand name or add
an individual query level to understand
a specific artist name or song name
for example
what this means is that you can get high
quality transcription no matter what
your use case is with the speech to text
API whether you're doing caption and
subtitles of media content or building a
virtual agent to interact with your
application it's easy to get started
right out of the box
for other use cases perhaps you're
taking the speech to text and using it
as part of a machine learning pipeline
or as part of something else that you
want to do with the text like
understanding the topics in it
summarizing it or doing sentiment
analysis
it's easy to use the speech to text API
as part of these pipelines as well and
whether you're interacting directly with
users or your consumer is a downstream
model we try to solve as many of the
challenges you might have as possible
dealing with different speakers
robustness to background noise or
different acoustic environments
detecting what languages users are
speaking sensitivity to specific words
or phrases if you know that you need to
pick up every time somebody says a
specific word as well as long complex
non-standard sentence phrasing depending
on your use case
all of this combined means it's super
easy to get started right out of the box
and then tune the API as you go for
whatever your needs may be
once you've transcribed speech from your
customers many of our customers also
want to be able to interact or speak
back to their users and that's where the
text-to-speech API comes in you can take
text and synthesize it into audio in one
simple step with the text-to-speech API
from Google Cloud
just like with with speech text it's
designed to work great out of the box so
we have over 400 voices that are
available that you can choose from in 50
plus different languages to synthesize
speech today
speaking of out of the box you get
access to Google's great text
normalization what this means is you
actually leverage information Google has
about how every word is pronounced in
different languages and you can use this
so that when you send text the first
time you don't have to worry about
passing custom pronunciations or
figuring out what phonemes make up the
word the way you want to say it
it works right out of the box for a
street name song names things like that
now of course just like with speech to
text we understand that sometimes you
need to customize your output in order
to get what you're looking for and
that's why the text-to-speech API has
full support for Lucid ssml markup which
will help you customize things like
porosity speed and past custom
pronunciations if you need them
now that we've talked about what's
available on the web or I want to talk
about what we're making available today
which is speech on device from Google
Cloud speech on device brings all the
great services that we've just talked
about available locally on embedded
devices this means that you can run our
speech models whether that's automatic
speech recognition or speech synthesis
directly on your embedded device with no
connectivity required this is great for
situations where you have low or no
connectivity or only very expensive
bandwidth options
it also helps preserve your user's
privacy because you can tell your users
that their voice and their speech is
never leaving the local device
now all of this is available without
having to compromise on quality these
aren't tour speech models that only work
for specific situations specific
commands or specific words these are the
same great models that you've used and
are used to on the cloud side available
to run locally with just a fraction of
the compute power necessary they expose
local services that can run on
multi-core arm processors whether
they're running Linux or Android
speech on device is available today so
you can contact your seller to learn
more and get started
I'm now going to hand it over to Ryan
wheeler from Toyota connected to tell us
more about how Toyota is leveraging
speech services in their vehicles today
Ryan
Alum thanks
so we knew we wanted to
voice experience possible for Toyota
customers that we would need to design
our own deep learning dialogue natural
language understanding system but a
portion of that for the speech
recognition we knew we needed to
leverage state-of-the-art technology as
well by partnering with Google we were
able to continuously deliver the best
speech to test text experience and the
best experience for Toyota customers
what this allowed us to do was to
rapidly develop machine learning systems
and rapidly develop apis and deploy code
very quickly
we also had the experience that every
time Google would make changes or
updates to their state-of-the-art deep
learning speech-to-text Technologies
Toyota customers constantly experience
those same updates for improvements to
the system overall
and then for the next generation of
multimedia services that Toyota
connected is looking to help develop we
knew that we needed a way to help
continue that local processing only one
of the things that we wanted to be able
to do was to offer the same experience
whether the customer was connected or
not or if you could imagine when you're
driving for offline or low connectivity
scenarios here we uniquely partnered
with Google and used their newly
developed speech on device technology to
create natural language understanding
systems that can run in low and no
connectivity environments all still
well-being state-of-the-art we also have
the ability that the customers can
choose to set privacy preserving
controls thereby giving them greater
control over what data is sent and
stored outside of the car
and now back to you Callum
thanks so much Ryan that's super
exciting to hear about how Toyota is
using speech services both in the cloud
and on device and I'm excited to
hopefully take advantage of them in my
next car being a Toyota Lexus thanks so
much
now I'm going to go back to talking
about the cloud and what's new and
available on the speech to text side for
our Cloud customers
back in April of 2022 we announced the
addition of the latest long and latest
short speech models
these models took advantage of new
research at the time from Google called
conformer models these are end-to-end
deep learning models that take audio and
convert it directly to text as opposed
to other ASR techniques which leverage
multiple intermediate steps and models
this makes it easier for us to optimize
towards quality as opposed to various
different intermediates what we've seen
is that we've gotten great increases in
robustness from this where we can get
better accuracy across different types
of accents and speakers as well as
different and unique acoustic
environments with things like background
noise or different types of microphones
ultimately we've seen the greatest gains
in accuracy on long-form speech and in
the variety of environments that I was
just talking about
we've heard great feedback from
customers about how they're using these
models and what they're doing with them
but we want to take it even further and
that's why today we're announcing the
availability of speech to text API V2 in
public preview
the goal of V2 is to help us take the
research that's coming from Google and
make it available to you our Enterprise
customers even faster
speech to text API V2 will follow a
modern resourceful API design this will
allow us to bring many new Google Cloud
wide features like uberment single
region data residency and Cloud audit
login to you as part of the speech to
text API
we've also designed it to be ready for
conformers and the future of speech
models this will allow us to bring these
models in as the everyday models as
opposed to just offering the latest
it will also set us up for Ultra large
speech models in the future and whatever
new things come down the pipe from
Google research
we also want to assure customers that
this doesn't mean the V1 API is going
away or that their Integrations will
break we're not deprecating the V1 API
and all of your requests will still
continue to work even if you don't
decide to migrate and change your code
to take advantage of speech text API V2
there's a whole bunch of great new
features and we really want to get your
feedback so please go check it out and
try it today it's available in public
preview
all right thank you so much for joining
me to hear about the speech services at
Google and how you can use them to power
your own speech and voice applications
uh thank you
[Music]